here's something you've never ever heard
before hey good question
you should bing it well you don't
believe me dang it
okay maybe once but except maybe as a
punch line
nobody uses bang microsoft has tried and
tried and tried again
they redesigned the website spent
millions advertising a pun
making google look better even paid
people to use it and yet a decade later
bing is still bing so at this point why
not just abandon the project
well because bing isn't actually a
failure far from it
it's a story of data and control and
ultimately the future of the internet
in 2012 ceo steve balmer announced bing
was finally a real contender he said by
reviewing our most popular searches or
showing bing is ready to compete with
the big boys
so what were they google google google
suicide
google and hot sauce hmm i mean when it
comes to spicy food the crown clearly
goes to bing
take that google ladies and gentlemen
steve
farmer but to be fair we should have
known bomber was no profit
after releasing the windows phone you
know that best-selling world-changing
sensation
he was so confident it would be
successful he held a funeral for the
iphone
literally iphones carried like caskets
yeah
so when i saw this chart of search
engine market share i wiped my
non-existent glasses
reloaded the page cleared the cache
restarted my computer threw it away and
bought a new one
but somehow it's true a third of us
internet searches use bing
26 in the uk 17 in canada and
like google they sell ads to the highest
bidder multiplied by over a billion
users a month and being it makes
five billion dollars a year as in one
two three four five six
seven eight nine zeros hundred dollar
bills stacked higher than the burj
khalifa
times five to put that in perspective
that's what youtube made with basically
no competitors
in 2016. the difference is bing actually
makes a profit
companies like twitter and snapchat lose
money for years
hoping money will come later and yet
here's bing actually in the black
hats off to you palmer oh wait but
seriously how can this be
and what does it mean
microsoft has had plenty of financial
ups and downs but one thing has always
been
consistent 82 percent of the world's
computers run windows
and that hasn't really changed besides
making a ton of money
this gives them an incredibly powerful
tool they'd be dumb
not to use in the same way a change to
the iphone is a change to the entire
industry
even the smallest adjustment to windows
has a huge effect among hundreds of
millions of devices
and that's especially true for one
simple reason people just don't change
their settings
microsoft lets you switch browsers and
search engines but ignorance and apathy
are on their side
people don't know how or don't care
enough to change them
making the defaults incredibly popular
internet explorer may not be
universally loved but it came with
windows so it doesn't matter
same with edge their new browser which
looks a little familiar
and they'll do anything to get more
users microsoft and apple may not be the
best of friends
but the enemy of my enemy is my friend
nearly all of google's revenue comes
from
search ads most of which are mobile and
even though only 12
are ios devices they make up 75
of that mobile revenue of course they'd
prefer you generate that money on
android
but in the meantime it's possible ios
users are worth more to google they
really benefit from and depend on apple
but the feeling isn't mutual
apple would love to keep a distance to
escape google maps they built
apple maps which wasn't so good at
keeping a distance
and this is where microsoft comes in in
2013
siri waved goodbye to google and hello
to bing but money can heal all wounds
google now sends apple a three billion
dollar check every year and apple says
fine you can be our default search
engine that's maybe the world's most
expensive
flip of a switch
the success of bing isn't really about
being it's about control
if people had to go out of their way to
find it nobody would
the difference between a five billion
dollar business and a completely
bankrupt one is the power to decide
what users see the decisions of tech
companies will often seem
strange and reckless like why pour so
much money into the windows and fire
phones
until you understand the larger goal
moving up the hierarchy of control
the strategy of entire companies entire
industries
is to climb this triangle the lower
something is the more companies it
relies on
and the greater its risk of being shut
down at the very bottom are plug-ins
extensions mods and hacks they
fundamentally depend on the
obliviousness or indifference of a
larger company who they often mean
very little to and when their goals
differ the larger company
always wins the hackintosh community for
example
trick mac os into running on their
custom-built computers
it's clever but if apple woke up on the
wrong side of the bed
they could end it faster than you could
say how do you like them apples
slightly higher are websites who can
send you any code they want but are at
the mercy of your browser to show
it and browsers like all apps are
beholden to the operating system who may
just say
nah i don't think so the company astro
makes an app to turn your ipad into an
extra computer monitor and they wanted
to add a button without covering the
screen
so they had a cool idea they'd use the
camera you
press it detects less light and
activates the button
a thumbs up from me but a thumbs down
from apple
who rejected it from the store or they
may really like your app
incorporate it into the os and kill your
business when max had a feature called
sherlock someone made a companion called
watson a 30 app with some extra features
but it was so good that it came with the
next version of mac os
and above all of these is the holy grail
of tech companies
physical devices when you own the
hardware you own
everything jeff bezos is the richest man
in the world not because he's good at
making profit
and certainly not because he's good at
labeling charts but because he
understands the power of getting amazon
in front of you
whatever the cost he would have happily
lost money on the fire phone
just to get in more people's hands
kindle fire tablets echo
they all make little or no profit but
they're incredibly important
it's the same reason windows phone
refused to quit for so
long and you can bet companies like
facebook hate
being in the hands of phone companies
please don't do it mark
they're gonna do it speaking of facebook
the other reason control is so important
is data more data means more and better
ads and ads
mean profit companies can buy it from
services like digime
who you can sell your private
information to for a few bucks
or companies can just get it themselves
and the higher on the triangle
the more they can collect it's a
terrible incentive that could forever
change the internet
in 2013 facebook suddenly felt
exceptionally generous
hey we should give everyone in the world
access to the internet so here's what
we're going to do
you get an internet you get an internet
everyone
gets an internet i know who i'm voting
for in 2020 but it's facebook so where's
the black mirror twist when users were
surveyed
something strange happened more people
said they used facebook than used the
internet
65 percent of nigerians and 61 percent
of indonesians
they asked agreed that facebook is the
internet and that's no
accident make no mistake what facebook
is so generously donating is not the
internet but
facebook's internet they only give
access to their website and a handful of
others which meet their requirements
no net neutrality in other words a
clever way to get more users
google is also getting into the
philanthropy business with what they
call
amp the technology is boring so here's a
summary what you see on a website is a
fraction of what's actually there
the rest is well garbage garbage that
tracks you for advertising makes the
site look fancy
whatever so google says all that garbage
is really slowing things down
why don't we host your website for you
we'll strip away that garbage and it'll
load faster
it sounds great but what do you know it
only works if you add to your website
the same garbage it's supposed to remove
because it isn't about speed so much as
control websites don't need google to
remove their garbage
if they want to load faster they can
just do it themselves google wants you
to hand them control of what users see
sure it's optional but if you say no you
rank lower in search results
so not really google and facebook
already have incredible control over the
internet but they like
all of it their dream isn't to dominate
the internet but to be
the internet and that's bad for everyone
the beauty of the internet is that the
power
isn't in the hands of any one company
anyone can do or learn
anything without the permission of a
google or a facebook
that's the power of a website like
brilliant.org you can take control of
your learning on topics like computer
science
math and physics behind all the
technology in this video are some really
fascinating concepts
like machine learning neural networks
and computational
logic all of which may sound
intimidating but are actually pretty fun
and rewarding to learn with brilliant
in too many of my classes and probably
yours too we're taught the steps to do a
problem but not really why
or how and that's because we're only
memorizing one specific problem
not actually understanding the process
the latter is what's actually
fun and useful in the real world and
that's what you get with brilliant you
practice the skills and see examples
along the way
here we're learning about how computers
store information there's an explanation
a visual and a chance to check our
understanding all very approachable
if we answer incorrectly it shows us
exactly how to get the solution
it really is a fantastic way to learn
especially if you're currently a student
or just like learning new things
you can support polymatter and learn
more at brilliant.org
polymatter and sign up for free the
first 200 people to use that link which
is in the description
will also get 20 off the annual premium
subscription
[Music]
you